antes de continuar quiero volver a
revisar el problema 180 pues aunque
encontramos la respuesta en el vídeo
anterior en cuanto lo termine me di
cuenta de que hay una manera más fácil
de resolverlo nos decían que en una
encuesta nacional una cuarta parte de
las personas respondió que si a la
primera pregunta
estos una tercera parte respondió
también que sí a la segunda pregunta nos
interesa conocer las personas que
respondieron si ambas un cuarto o una
tercera parte de un cuarto es igual a un
doceavo
un 20 de la población dijo que si a
ambas por lo que los que respondieron no
alguna fueron todos los demás así que
restamos un doceavo a 12 12 a bozzo al
entero
12 12 a bosch menos un doceavo
va a ser igual a 11 doceavos de la
población que es la respuesta correcta
bueno ya ha aclarado esto ahora sí
sigamos con la siguiente pregunta
problema número 181 la proporción de dos
cantidades es tres a cuatro si cada una
de ellas se incrementa en 5 como
cambiara la proporción entre ellas bueno
esto va a depender de qué múltiplos sean
de 3 o 4 estas cantidades y me da la
impresión de que no hay suficiente
información para responder lo vamos a
demostrar que puedo tener dos respuestas
diferentes con esta misma información
por ejemplo vamos a decir que no sé x va
a ser igual a 3 esta es mi primera
cantidad
la proporción va a ser igual a 4x y ya
son las dos cantidades que tienen esta
proporción 3 a 4
aquí está o también puedo decir que x es
igual a 6 y james va a ser igual a 8 que
también tienen esta proporción 3 a 4 si
yo en esta le sumó 5 a la x el aiem x 5
va a ser igual a 538 y gemma 5 va a ser
igual a 4 598 novenos
si hago lo mismo de este otro lado x + 5
x + 5 es igual a 6 5 11
/ g 5 es igual 85 13 11 13 a 28 novenos
es diferente a 11 3 seamos así que puede
encontrar una equis y una que cumplen
con esta condición pero al aumentarse en
5 me dan dos respuestas diferentes por
lo que no puedo resolverlo con la
información dada y esta es mi opción
siguiente pregunta problema número 182
si el promedio o media aritmética de x
60 y el promedio de 17 es 80
cuál es el valor de z - x reescribimos
esto como x más el promedio entre 2 o x
más entre dos que su promedio nos dicen
que es igual a 60
el promedio de y y ceta s maceta entre 2
nos dicen que esto es igual a 80 nos
están preguntando z - x
esto es lo que queremos encontrar vamos
a multiplicar aquí 2 en ambos lados de
la ecuación y nos queda x +
igual a 120 despejamos aquí x estamos ya
en ambos lados nos queda que x es igual
a 120 menos y aparte de este lado
hagamos lo mismo multiplicamos 2 en
ambos lados me queda más z es igual a
160 despejamos de este lado z me va a
quedar que 7 es igual a 160 menos james
ahora sustituyamos esta x y esta zeta
aquí en la presión que nos piden z 160 -
james menos x que es 120 menos esto es
igual
160 120 es 40 menos menos por menos es
más
- gemma si se van a cancelar esto es
igual a 40 y es mi opción b
siguiente problema número 183 si la
mitad del aire en un tanque se elimina
con cada golpe de la bomba de vacío cual
fracción de la cantidad original de aire
se eliminó después de cuatro golpes
vamos a escribir esta información me
dicen que se va la mitad del contenido
del tanque con cada golpe esto es la
mitad del tanque
tanques
por golpe de la bomba
veamos cuánto se retira y cuánto queda
con cada golpe
tenemos lo que se queda en el tanque
y lo que se retira con cada golpe
un golpe dos golpes tres golpes cuatro
golpes con el primer golpe se va la
mitad
y queda la mitad del tanque
con el segundo golpe de lo que queda se
va a ir la mitad la mitad de un medio va
a ser igual a un cuarto y nos va a
quedar un 4
de este cuarto que queda en el tercer
golpe se va a ir otra mitad la mitad de
un cuarto es un octavo se va un octavo y
se queda un octavo de hecho creo que no
era necesaria esta columna pero bueno
para el cuarto golpe será es la mitad de
este octavo me va a quedar un
dieciseisavo y esto es lo que nos queda
en el cuarto golpe pero nos están
preguntando cuál es la fracción de la
cantidad original si esto lo que nos
queda vamos a restar los del entero
tenemos la cantidad original que estaba
el tanque lleno menos un dieciseisavo
qué es lo que queda eso es lo mismo que
tener 16 dieciseisavos
me entero menos un 16 ago igual a 15
dieciseisavos
siguiente problema número 184 si los
enteros de dos dígitos m y n son
positivos y tienen los mismos dígitos
pero en orden inverso cuál de los
siguientes no puede ser la suma de m y n
imaginemos que está m tiene los dígitos
a y b no sé cuáles sean pero los voy a
llamar así y m tiene estos mismos
dígitos pero invertidos tendrá primero a
b y luego a qué pasa si los sumamos si
sumo a b
ah
bueno en el dígito unitario quedará de
acuerdo en b más a quedar esta parte de
más
y tendrá el dígito de las escenas
a más de esto asumiendo que ve
más a la suma es menor a 10
y viendo las opciones que nos quedan las
opciones a veces no cumplen con lo que
acabamos de encontrar ahora veamos el
caso de que vemos a es mayor a 10 que
pasa cuando ven más
es mayor que 10 o mayor o igual a 10 si
hacemos esta suma a más ave más ve más a
más fe más sano más vea el número
vamos a tener más
en el unitario en el dígito unitario de
más a pero como esta suma es mayor o
igual a 10 voy a tener un 1 que se su
marca
y aquí voy a tener a b1 a ba1 que venía
de la suma de masa y aquí hay dos
opciones que coinciden veamos
tenemos aquí vamos a tener esta suma
también es mayor o igual a 10 y más con
este 1 que se agregó así que esto va a
ser un número de dos dígitos esta parte
de acá vamos a tener un número así con
tres elementos y las opciones que nos
dan 165 unos 65 sabemos que el número de
en medio va a ser la suma de estos dos
más uno así que este número de acá y que
esté en medio va a ser mayor por una
unidad que el de las unidades este la
cumple unos 65 la opción c que es 121
también cumplen con esto este del medio
es mayor en una unidad que éste y la
opción que no lo cumple es la opción
así que esta es mi respuesta correcta
este problema estuvo bastante
interesante nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo